así que aquí tenemos una imagen de la
molécula del cubano que es un arcano que
tiene una figura de cubo y por estas
razones que es una de mis moléculas
favoritas y puedes ver por ejemplo que
en cada una de estas esquinas del cubo
tenemos un carbono y que además cada uno
de ellos está unido a un único hidrógeno
así que por esto es la fórmula molecular
del cubano es de 8 h 8 muy bien entonces
en principio algunos químicos decían que
esta molécula no podría hacerse debido a
que tiene muchísimas restricciones
angulares verdad pero esta molécula fue
fue hecha cerca de 1960 y
digamos que se le ha estado buscando
muchas aplicaciones potenciales en
medicina y en explosivos en estos días y
esto es porque podemos nitrogenado y
hacer algunas cosas como el octa nitro
cubano o el ept a nitro cubano que son
explosivos potenciales para el futuro
ahora lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
es ver si podemos darle un nombre al
cubano utilizando la nomenclatura de
iupac ok vamos a tratar de pensar en
todas las reglas que hemos aprendido en
el vídeo de nomenclatura de compuestos
bicicl y cos ahora si estamos tratando
de descubrir cuántos anillos hay en este
sistema tenemos que hacer algunos cortes
para descubrir cuántos necesitamos para
obtener una cadena de alcano digamos
abierta sin sin ciclos verdad así que si
empezamos en esta versión amarilla y que
quizás aquí faltó esta línea de aquí si
empezamos en ese lado necesitamos ver
cuántos cortes necesitamos para dejarlo
como una cadena abierta de alcaldes
entonces podríamos hacer primero este
that podríamos hacer primero este y ahí
tendríamos un corte luego podríamos
hacer el corte de esta verdad y ahí
tendríamos dos cortes los cortes
podríamos dar un tercer corte digamos no
sé podríamos dar el corte de aquí abajo
y de ahí tendríamos tres y de aquí ya
debe ser mucho más claro que necesitamos
dos por ejemplo este de aquí y este otro
de aquí así que en realidad necesitamos
cinco cortes para llevar este cubano a
una estructura de un arcano que solo es
una cadena abierta verdad entonces lo
que sea que esto sea va a ser algo como
un venta ciclo venta ciclo muy bien y
aquí vamos a considerar vamos a hacer de
cuenta que esto es una estructura bi
cíclica y aquí lo puse en blanco si nos
damos cuenta aquí debería ser un poco
obvio que estos dos carbonos son
nuestros carbonos cabeza de puente
verdad entonces ahí tenemos nuestra
estructura bi cíclica y tenemos que
hacerlo
hacer digamos las mismas reglas que
teníamos en el vídeo anterior entonces
vamos a ir enumerando digamos que este
es nuestro primer carbono y podemos
enumerar hacia arriba verdad porque es
nuestra cadena más larga entonces vamos
al 2 3 4 5 y ya regresamos a la otra
cabeza que 6 y luego nos seguimos verdad
con la segunda cadena más larga que es 7
8 muy bien entonces ya ahí tenemos la
enumeración ahora simplemente hacemos
hacemos las mismas reglas que cuando
teníamos compuestos be cíclicos verdad
pondremos en el primer en este primer
número el número de carbonos que tiene
la cadena más larga eliminando las
cabezas y en este caso serían tendríamos
1 2 3 y 4 verdad tendríamos 4 átomos de
carbono luego pondríamos cuántos átomos
de carbono tiene la cadena la segunda
cadena más larga quitando las cabezas y
esos son dos verdad entonces tenemos
cuatro dos y finalmente cuántos tiene la
tercera cadena más larga pero entre las
cabezas no hay carbonos así que
tendremos un cero ok entonces hasta aquí
terminamos digamos considerando los
compuestos be cíclicos ahora simplemente
tenemos que considerar los enlaces que
nos faltan por ejemplo tenemos un enlace
o hay conexiones entre el 2 y el 5
entonces lo que vamos a poner es un cero
porque no hay carbonos entre el 2 y 5
pero están con
entonces aquí un 0 25 que otro tenemos
un 0 entre el 3 y el 8 verdad aquí
entonces son hay una conexión entre el 3
y el 8 pero sin carbono es verdad en
medio y finalmente tenemos este esta
conexión entonces son 0 0 carbonos entre
el 4 y 7 aunque están conectados y aquí
cerramos nuestro corchete verdad aquí
cerramos nuestro corchete y debemos
terminar con el tipo de alcano al que
nos estamos refiriendo y sabemos que el
cubano tiene 8 átomos de carbono
entonces este es un octano muy bien así
que esta es la nomenclatura de es del
cubano según new bac sería el penta
ciclo 4 200 253 y aquí aquí van puntos
sería 0 38 y 0 4.7 octano ok y en
realidad hay muchísimas otras moléculas
que son similares al cubano que también
son bastante interesantes así que
algunas moléculas como como el dow de
cátedra no podría ser uno que podría
revisar si es que te gustó la estructura
del cubano